Good morning.
Good morning. All Good Morning, z Morning, sir.
Okay, we'll start in few minutes.
We'll wait for a few minutes.
Alright, so now let us start.
Okay, so I'll just, uh, start with a quick
recap from the LSTM that how does
LSTM work We have already seen in the last class,
but we'll have the quick recap of that.
You can ask some question.
I will first explain you with some numerical, uh, intuition
that how does those operations in the input gate, uh,
for gate, gate and output gate happens.
We can have some discussion on those.
And then my plan is to take you through, uh, the,
and explain one of the, um, LSTM use case that is,
uh, as a, as a language model.
Okay? So for next word, prediction task, how
to use the LSTM.
So that is what I have thought of. So we'll do that today.
Let me share my screen.
Good morning, sir. Morning.
Okay.
Alright. So, uh,
we have already talked about the motivation
behind this l SST architecture that there was some problem,
or you can say the limitations in the RNN cell,
that it cannot, uh, remember the longer context
because that is not what is involved in the architecture.
So we have a single hidden estate,
which we are keep on updating, for example, you see that
every time when we feed the current input.
We also have the input coming from the last hidden estate.
And then we update everything here in the last head
and state this, this line, upper line,
the last head and state line.
We update that itself, uh, using this gate
where we have 10 activation function.
And then this, this line itself goes to the next timestamp.
So what is happening is the, this particular vector online,
whatever you can say it is now responsible
for the short term context also,
which is the xt XT minus one, XT plus two.
These are the short term, the current context,
what it is processing, as well as it is also responsible
to remember the longer context.
What it will see, say that xt hundred.
So the same vector will keep on updating
in every time stamp.
And hence, it's very likely that it will, uh, lose some
of the information in between, right?
So this was the main problem in the, in the RNN,
that it was going towards the vanishing ingredient.
And hence we tried to address that with the help
of this LSTM architecture.
We said that, let us have a separate line for my memory.
Okay? The hidden state is one thing, which anyway, we will,
uh, calculate for every time, time,
but then we'll have a separate vector
or separate line for my memory.
And what we'll do is based on the current context, we'll try
to update our memory update.
When I say you can just forget something from the
existing knowledge, you can add something to the
existing knowledge, right?
And then, yeah, these two are the operation, what we do at,
in, at my memory level.
And then in the, uh, like
that's why we had the forget gate input gate
and the output gate.
Were responsible for giving the, uh, output
for the agent next, uh, at the last hidden state.
So see in the memory, you may have many things,
but you don't want to expose everything.
So in the, this is the four gate gate, the first,
first gate here, we, you have the sigmoid.
This is, this is a neural network
or layer sigmoid is just a representation that we are going
to use the activation function as sigmoid.
But you may have many neurons here coming together.
Say that four neurons are here, okay?
So all the four neurons gets the,
except the input from the XT
and HT minus one, there is one more.
This one HT minus one.
This line, do all the calculation like weighted sample plus
bias and pass it through the activation funds.
And sigmoid, sigmoid will give you the output as a vector.
That vector will get multiply
with this vector point twice pointwise multiplication.
So the shape of the vector doesn't
change, value will change.
So sigmoid decides how much to, for forget
based on this current context, what to remember, what to
for forget that is what this sigmoid decides.
So it value, it, it values vary between zero one.
Now, this second gate was the input gate where the, first
of all, we were identifying the candidate cell.
That means that based on the current context,
what is the new information which we should be knowing so
that the standard was, uh, responsible for getting
that new information.
But out of that new information, how much to be added
to my memory, because new information is based on xt,
but complete xt, I should add to my memory or partial
or, uh, none that all decided by again, the sigmoid.
Okay? So that's why the combination of these two.
First we get multiply, we get a vector.
That vector, whatever vector which is coming from here,
we'll add it into that.
So it'll add the new information into the my, uh,
uh, my memory cell.
And finally we had the output gate.
So output gate, as I said, that idea is very simple.
See, you, we have a lot of information in our brain, right?
Um, a lot of experience.
But when you are a particular short term context,
suppose you are in office
and you are working for a particular project,
you always give the output based on that project.
You don't give the output based on the classes what you are,
uh, attending in the,
and take, maybe you can take some of them also,
or you don't talk about the family, uh,
thing when you are in the office.
So what I'm trying to say is, in our brain,
we have many things, long-term, short-term context,
many things we have, it's like a memory.
But what, when we converge with someone
based on the current context, we only, uh, explain, uh,
we only give the output based on that current context,
not the everything what we have in my brain, right?
So this HT minus one is something like that,
that this upper cell CT is my whole memory.
And st minus one is like, okay, part, part of that memory,
which is important based on this current input, say
that this is a query question and I have to give an answer.
I'll apply my mind, but in my mind I have multiple things.
I'll give only that thing which is relevant for this query.
So that is s st minus one. Okay?
So this is what is the work of the, uh, output gate.
Now anyway, these all things you have seen,
what I have decided that I will, uh, explain you a little,
uh, in detail based on the,
uh, some, some example, okay?
So that it would be more clear
to you that what is happening.
So say that I have a sentence I love deployed, right?
So first of all, the,
if I have only these four words in my whole vocabulary,
the vocabulary side will be four.
I guess all of you can understand that.
And you know that the way we process this one will be,
first we have to convert them into one hot vector.
One hot vector size will be four. Why?
Because vocabulary size is four
and one of the index will be high.
So say that for I first index is high rest.
Three values are zero. Okay?
So, uh, uh, let me just draw it.
So we, we will just represent everything as a vector.
I love deep learning as a vector.
Only thing is it'll be a one hot vector.
So say that I'm telling that my vocabulary size is four.
So every, every, uh,
word here say I will be represented like that.
Because my first index is I'm giving the index number one
to I now for love this vector, we be like,
this will be zero and this will be one.
Okay? So 0 1, 0, 0. Similarly for deep it'll be 0, 0, 1, 0.
So this will also will be 0, 0, 0, 1, 0.
And for learning, it'll be 0, 0, 0 1. Okay?
This is the initial thing, what we do.
So once we have that representation, uh, ready for this, uh,
uh, each of these world, then what we do,
we pass it through the embedding term.
Embedding layer, right? Usually we do that, right?
Because my vocabulary size are in, uh, in the real case,
it'll be too high, like 1000, 10,000.
And getting a one hot vector with 10,001 hot vector is,
is like just a waste of resources and computations, right?
And even there is no meaningful information in zeros.
So what we do, we compress that and we get the dense vector.
Say that here, dense vector dimension is also four. Okay?
So one hot vector will be converted into another uh, vector.
And there also we have only four values,
but this time there is no zero.
There is some values like positive, negative,
some flow point, and so on, okay?
Till this much we have seen, and I'll explain you
and I'll show you the demo also that how to add this layer.
We have seen in the case of RNN when we are seeing
the demo for that one.
Now, after this say that, uh,
once we have embedding dimension, embedding layer done,
then we are just, uh, deciding what should be my batch size.
Okay? Here, because I have only one sentence.
So I'm taking the batch size as one,
but batch size will vary.
Okay? Batch size means,
suppose you have thousand such sentences in your data,
I decide to process 32 data at a time.
I'll show you in the demo today that how
to create that batch size.
Okay? But here I'm showing for simplicity.
It is one sequence, length is anyway, four,
it is decided here based on this particular, uh,
length of the sequence.
Time is stamp one, I will be processed.
Time is stamp two, love will be processed.
Then three deep than forward learning.
Likewise, sequence length is four.
In the batch size, there are little more, uh, uh,
pre-processing, which is required
because see, what will happen when suppose you decide
to process 32 uh, sentences at a time,
all sentence may vary in length.
So you may have to do a little bit of padding for,
because for a particular batch, you have to tell to the LSTM
that how many sequence length you are passing.
Now, for one sentence, it's very clear.
Whatever is the length of sentence,
that will be my time stamped number four.
But for the batch size, you have to do the padding, right?
I'll show you that in the demo as will.
So sequence length here is four means four timestamp.
We are going to process
and finally each timestamp for each, for each
of these word, what is the dimension in
which you're representing them.
So the embedding dimension is four, so which is also equal
to here, my DV equal 2D.
So this is nothing but D. So one cross four cross four.
Initially it'll be one cross four cross V.
Later it'll be one cross four cross D. Okay?
I, I hope you are able
to understand it, what I'm trying to say.
So we, I'm just preparing my XT here, okay?
I'm preparing my XT.
So XT will be in one, cross four cross
one is the batch side, four is the, okay,
what is the sequence length?
So four timestamp, it will go
and each word will have the four dimensional vector
as an input here, okay?
That is one thing. What you have to understand.
Now, uh, after embedding layer also I have
my dimension will not change.
It'll be one for cross four, cross four
because D is equal to four.
I'm taking, okay, so that's why this is not changing.
Otherwise it would've changed.
Now say that my input is now one cross four, cross four.
Now for going forward, uh, I think, uh,
earlier also I have mentioned it, this xt,
this s st minus one
and this CT minus one here, candidate cell.
The last, uh, uh, ct, ct, my memory cell, you can say that
candidate memory cell.
So far, they're all vectors.
First of all, what you have to treat them as a vector
and they're all of same dimension.
They cannot vary in dimension.
You can't have four dimensional input here
and 10 dimensional output here.
No, that is not, that is not the possible otherwise
because the operation, what I'm going to perform here
and here it is a point wise operation, okay?
Vector operation. So vector operation,
your two vectors should be of same size,
same dimension, okay?
So this ct, ht xt, they're all of same dimension.
So, so IP support, I have decided my
input is a four dimension.
So XT will also will be a four dimension, okay?
Uh, xt, which is an input will be a four
dimension hidden state.
This one s st minus one.
This will will also be a four dimension CT minus one will
also be a four dimension by default.
This is how the setup will be in the lst, okay?
You can't have the varying dimension for these vectors.
And all of them are vectors.
Not a single, it's not a scaler,
it's not a single value collection of values.
It is fine. Now, XT s st minus one,
CT one R vectors not a scaler.
And each LS TM gate has four neural. One more thing.
What I am doing here is these gates
where I'm showing the sigmoid sigmoid 10 x sigmoid.
Okay? These four are the gates.
I said that these are all the neural network.
So if it is a neural network, there must be some neuron.
I'm assuming that there is only one layer neural network.
All of these are only one layer, okay?
Single layer neural network.
But there will be some number of neurons
because they are the neural network.
So I am considering there are four neurons here,
only four neurons.
Why four neurons? Once we have the four neurons here,
the output, what it'll give will be four output.
Why Four output I require,
because my CT minus one is of dimension four.
That is what I have decided. CT minus one is four.
That's why whatever is the dimension of this CT minus one,
ST minus one or xt and all of them are going to be same.
Accordingly, you have to decide
how many neurons you are going to keep here.
Okay? So that is, that is very, very important.
Then only the ft,
what you will get will have the same dimension
as CT minus one.
Otherwise in the FT or IT
or ct, you will get the dimension, say 10,
because you are keeping here 10 neurons and CT is only four.
You can't do the vector, uh,
pointwise multiplication or addition.
You understand that, right? So this is
by default you only have to, uh, uh, uh, just, just uh,
see that, uh, the number of neurons, what you're, uh,
keeping in fact,
uh, that will be taken care.
That will be taken care. You don't have to show you the demo
and you, uh, but this is what happens internally, right?
So yeah, the LSTM gait has four neurons that is supposed,
I have decided here.
I also have four neuron, four neuron,
four neuron PHN for, for all gait.
I have four neurons right now. Let us see that.
What happened in the four GA gate.
So four GA gate, very simple.
What four GA gate is, does it do,
it does the weighted surplus bias,
weighted sum in the sense, suppose we have XD
and it has the, uh, it is multiplied with the weight.
Say that xf, okay?
Uh, this, this is the, this is what I'm saying.
So XT will get multiplied with the weight here.
ST minus one will get multiplied with the weight TL,
yet it was shown a W no.
Okay? So I'm just expanding this one
where it is now here in the form of vector representation,
I'm writing them separately.
So this is one weight gets multiplied with xt,
another weight gets multiplied with HT minus one.
Simple as usual for any neuron.
This is what we do plus bias.
Now this will give me one value, okay?
Consider that xt is this xt, XT minus one, CT minus one.
Remember I said they are all of the same dimension
and see that they have some value, okay?
They have some value. This is the current input, okay?
This is the current input XT say that I'm processing.
I so XT now representing my I st minus one is
last year in outputs.
You can ask from where you got this, I am saying
that it is randomly dec, uh, randomly I have initialized.
I don't know because when we are starting
this ST minus one CT minus one is all zeros.
Either you can write 0, 0, 0, 0
or you can write some value randomly, which you can update.
So this, uh, but the best practice is to have,
you can start with zero, no problem.
Okay? But say that this is what we have right now, okay?
Uh, uh, when I'm starting this is
what is these three factors I have then what we do.
First of all, we calculate this W
into X plus W into ST minus one plus B
and say that that value is coming at JF,
this internal linear, this is a linear function, right?
Linear combination of weight, uh, input and bias, right?
So that is coming at JF suppose,
suppose this is just a representation.
And when you multiply xd, which say that I have not here,
I'm not showing you where, what is W-X-F-W-H-F,
you can imagine, right?
It is four across four um, weight metrics
because Y four cross four,
because here the input is also four dimension, okay?
And the number of neurons, what you're using is also four.
So four input will get multiplied with four neurons,
four across four 16 weights do want.
And that is what it is written here. It's four across four.
Similarly for here, four across four, okay, so now say that
after doing all those multiplication,
the internal value is set F
and that is coming as this vector,
which is having four dimension, four value.
Now that will be passed to the sig mite
because this is the sig mite gate, okay?
This is the forget gate where I have a sig mite function
and that will result the ft.
That will result the ft.
So when you are seeing this, it is passing
to the sig mite resulting in ft.
What we are doing sig mite, uh,
of 1.2 is a 1.77 sigmoid
of minus 0.5 is 0.38.
Sigmoid of 0.3 is 0.57.
And sigmoid of 2.0 is 0.8. That is what you're getting.
That is what is the ft. That is what is the ft.
So now once we have this ft, now it has to multiply.
You see this, once we have this ft, it has
to, it has to this.
So here you're getting ft.
It has to multiply with the CT minus one, okay?
With the CT minus one as you can see here.
So I'll go forward and show you that.
So FT has to multiply,
but the point wise multiplication,
element wise multiplication.
So you can see that FT is coming as this vector 0.7,
1.3 8.5, 1.58.
That is one. And then I have CT minus one,
which I have decided to start with that 0.9, 0.2, 0.8 0.4,
you see that pointwise multiplication means element wise,
the first element here gets
multiplied with first element here.
Second element here gets multiplied with second.
That is called pointwise or element wise.
But that will result you another vector.
And this is this vector 0.6 9.08, 0.46 and 0.35.
Mm-hmm. So now you can understand, right?
So what is happening is based on my current input XD
and ST minus one, my forget gate, decide
how much I have to forget from the current cell
estate, okay?
What I have to forget from the current, so current ate says
that, that your memory is represented at 0.7
0.3 8.5 7.8.
You see that what the sigma has done FT has done 0.77.
It is only retaining as 0.69.
Miss it is forgetting some
of the element from this dimension.
Some of the information 0.38 is, is drastically removed.
Now it is only 0.0, 0.08,
0.57 is now 0.46 and 0.88 is now 0.35.
So what is happening is, now this is very important
because this is the sigmoid.
It gets multiplied if value is close to one.
So this one, sorry, this, this,
the second one is very important.
Value is close to one.
Keep that information value is close to zero.
Then forget that information
and anything in between you filter that information, okay?
That is what is the four gate. Gate.
And this is what it happens internally also, okay,
this is the multiplication.
What has happened. So suppose somewhere it is zero,
this whole dimension will be zero.
If it is one, then it'll come as it is.
And that means that I want to keep this dimension of this,
uh, cell estate as it is.
I don't want to forget anything from that
or I want to forget everything here.
Everything like you're forgetting something.
Here it is more, uh, um,
right here it is less and so on, okay?
Calculations wise you can see whether it is correct or not.
I'm trying to give you the intuition.
Now, once it is done, then it is input gate
and candidate, uh, that input gate.
You can say that, right? So input gate, if you go back
and see that this one, so first we calculate it
and then we calculate ct.
So what we say that based on the current input XT
and ST minus one, we have to add something into
because anyway, we have forgotten whatever I have
to forget based on this current input now,
but maybe we need to add something also.
So what we have to add, so basically these two
neural network together decide what to be added.
So first of all, we calculate this candidate cell CT dash,
which is telling that what new information to be added,
how much new information to be added to ct, my memory.
But that is the, uh, that is what is the ct.
What I'm saying that, okay, this information I'm now,
today I'm learning deep learning.
So I'm saying, okay, deep learning is a new concept for me.
I should add everything to my memory.
But then this, it will decide no,
deep learning is just a part of machine learning.
You should not, uh, add into your memory deep learning.
I just separate subject,
but you have to link it with the machine learning.
So everything need not to be added.
So in, you can treat this as a machine learning on top of
that, you can understand it as a neural network.
So that is what it decide by it.
So CT is like what new to add.
It is like, okay, in that new how much to be added. Okay?
So I'll say, okay, 10, this is the amount what I have
to add, but it will say no, only you add 90% of the 10.
That is nine to be added.
So it decides what is the fraction of the new information
to be added, okay?
It decide what is the fraction
of the new information to be added, right?
So that is what is this IT and CT together, they add here,
but before that they get multiply.
That's why, uh, the 0.5 multiplication, same thing.
It is shown here. So say that I calculate it here.
You see that before it,
I have something coming from inside this.
So ZI say this is ZI and I say this is ZC, okay?
The linear combinations, whatever we are doing,
and pass it to the sigma here, pass it to standard here.
So that is coming as it as this vector ct, as this vector.
And you see that dimension of all
of them are same dimension cannot change.
Now, once it is CT candidate cell, um, uh,
you have first of all you'll multiply them.
So you will multiply them, pointwise,
pointwise multiplication will happen, it multiplication,
and then you will add, then you will add
whatever you are getting from the
or from the four gate gi, from this one FT two C team.
Because if you see there are diagram,
what you're adding here, whatever you, you're getting
after the four, four gig, this vector, so this vector,
how much we got earlier, this vector was like 0.6 9.08.
This is what we'll add. Okay? This is what we'll add.
So you see that this is what we have 0.6 9.08
that we are adding to the whatever we have done
after the multiplication of it and ct.
And that is now, okay, this is the, uh, um, output
of the sate after the input gate, fine.
And finally the third gate, that is called output gate.
So what happened now, my memory is already updated based on
the current input or current context, okay?
Xt. And now I need to, uh, uh, expose something
as an output that, okay, based on this current input
and whatever cell state I have, what is the, uh,
immediate output I can expose for the next ate,
which is going to next LSTM cell,
which is going to come, okay?
Because timestamp manner, we are processing it.
I'm still at I then deep, I then love will come,
then deep will come, then learning will come.
So I need to process, I need
to give two output sate anywhere created.
What is the output which we are giving HT minus one.
So again, what will happen, first of all, from the ct, you,
what you do is, I, I was giving you the, uh, intuition
of this one was that you have the memory.
In your memory, you have the, uh,
what you did in your childhoods, you remember what you did,
uh, in what you do in your office.
You remember what you're planning
for the next week, you remember.
But then if I ask you what is lstm,
you will not start explaining me, okay, next week I'm going
for this trip with my family, right?
If I ask you what is lstm, you will say that, okay,
there is an input gate or gate and all these things.
Why? Because this is the current xd you are processing
and you're giving me the output.
So this ST is like, okay, based on this current context,
what is the immediate output?
And CT is like everything,
what you have in your brain, okay?
So you filter some of the things from CT
and give it as an xd.
Okay? So that is what is the xd
and that is what we process here with this output gate.
So first of all, whatever is the ct, we, we
extract some information, uh, from, uh, in the tanach.
And this OT is anyway, you are deciding,
uh, via the sig mite.
Sig mite always give you the range as, uh, say that, uh,
between, you can see that right T is like 0.75, 0.40,
0.65, 0.82.
And my ct, CT is, is this one.
Uh, say that last, if I'll see CT 0.8940.
Uh, okay, so 10 H of ct, 10 H of ct,
I have done 10 H of ct, which has come at 0.71.
So this ct, I'm, I passed it through the 10 H
and say that it is common.
So these values, you don't have to bother.
I have just taken it as a, um, example.
So 10 H of CT has come like this.
OT has come like this, then you will multiply again,
pointwise, whatever you will result.
That is st the immediate, uh, the output which you are going
to pass it to the next time step.
So that's all. So ATE is store long-term memory.
The upper line in the ostium that is stored,
the long-term memory and output get control.
What is the, uh, term context or short term, uh, output.
What you're going to give based on the current input hidden
estate is filtered view of memory.
So LS TM separates the memory stories
from the memory exposure.
So what I'm trying to say is LSTM always keep these
two, two things separately.
What is my memory, which is running from my, since my birth,
that is one city
and this SD is like, okay, based on the immediate
or short term context, what what I'm giving the exposure.
So that is, so these two things, elast m always try
to keep separately, okay?
So I'll just stop here maybe for the quick, uh,
queries and answer.
Then I will go further depth,
Sir. Morning sir.
Now this, uh, what I understand is
that this gate, so it is not
manually we defend it is the network which automatically
learns, uh, like when to take the previous history
or, uh, how much the percentage
of the memory we have to consume, right? Exactly,
Exactly. So as
I was giving you example now support,
my question will be what is LSTM?
So what you will do, you will see that, okay,
what is explained in this class or in the last class or,
and based on that you try to give them answer, right?
So it is like, it is like, uh, in your memory you may have
the understanding that understanding you try
to give in the form of PhD, everything you don't say,
but you try to filter that from your memory,
what is the correct output for this query,
and you give as an output.
Understood. So now this type of, uh,
automatically the network learns by itself.
So it depends upon again, that, uh, the final, uh, loss
function, which you yes, yes, yes.
So based on that, it
It all depends on what output you want
to get at the final timestamp that will give you the loss
and loss will anyway, it'll back propagate. Yes.
Okay. Understood sir. Thank you.
Correct. That's dedicated to output,
uh, close to one you're concerning and zero year targeting.
What is the in between value?
In between values are these?
So I was just explaining you everything.
That's why with the, for example, uh,
this is ha sigmoid in between values are this.
When you pass it through the sigmoid, it, it may give
because sigmoid always range, which means zero
and one including zero and one.
So it may, for each of these values, it may result you zero,
it may result you one, it may result you in between.
So in between value, like it is coming 0.77, 0.38,
0.57, 0.8.
These are the in between value zero and one.
And what we are doing is the 0.7 7 3 8 5 7,
we are multiplying it with, with my memory,
the current memory and it decide, okay,
if it is 0.77 only this much, this much, I have to,
uh, uh, multiplying will this much I have to carry
and rest of the things I have to forget this much.
I have only 20% I have to carry. Just I have to forget.
Okay? So that is what it tells,
because somehow I have to quantify it that what I,
how much I'm forgetting or how much I'm keeping.
So this, uh, sig mite helps us in that. Yeah,
This is the first, for the first word,
Same thing will happen for all the
Board for the second. Yes.
Yeah, same thing. So initially it's, so for initially
for FT and ct, we have randomly assigned the wait, ah,
because there is no previous wait,
it'll get updated. Yes sir.
There is no such previously all these are like some value
I have taken, right?
Yes, sir. But uh, you can start with zero, as I said.
Yes sir. Yes. Okay. The ct, uh, HT minus one,
CT minus one, these two value, whatever I have taken,
you can start with 0, 0, 0, 0 to best.
Okay? To understand, because
initially you don't have any memory.
Yes. And coming from back,
now slowly you can update everything,
but I have taken some value
to give you the, uh, some instruction. Yeah, that's,
Yeah. Yes,
Sir. In this funded
gate also, we initialized that bias
to one sir, like we do in other neural networks
or there also, we take it to zero to one.
Uh, no. So see bias value always you,
we we we keep it as one.
One, yeah, usually, I mean you can always vary.
This is tuneable, okay?
The previous class you mentioned, uh,
vector output vector cannot be same as input, correct?
But here we are using input
and output, uh, as the same size of same dimension.
So because of the 100 dimension, we are following the same,
No, no. What I'm
saying is, uh, in this network, when you see, uh,
I, uh, I think I mentioned,
I don't know which context you're saying
that these all vectors, xt, XT minus one, CT minus one or ft
or it ct, ot, all these has
to be of same dimension.
There is no chance they can,
because I have to do the pointwise multiplication,
pointwise addition, pointwise multiplication,
pointwise multiplication.
So now I need two vectors of same number of elements.
So there are point multiplication cannot happen. Okay?
So they all have, they all have to be same dimension.
So all, all these uh, gates are like kind
of good gates only, right?
Because I see all of them will have a weight,
which won't be one.
Uh, so the obvious tends to, uh, tune down the values.
So the key, so here we have all weights.
So the actually XT how it is connected
with the neuron via some weight, it's a fundamental
of any neural network, right?
So XT connected with these.
So you just, where are all our weights?
You can ask me where and all our weights available.
The weights are only available
where these gates are available
because these gates are nothing
but a neural network neurons.
So these neurons are connected with two inputs only,
XD and T minus one.
So there is a one set
of weight which is going from XD one set of weight,
which is going from SD minus one.
And these two are the weights. That's all here.
We don't have any weights here.
We don't have any weights here. We don't have any weights.
Weights are wherever you have the neurons, that's
All. Okay?
Okay. Yeah. Okay,
because I, I was saying like, uh, when you say forget, um,
uh, right CT minus one, right?
And, and because we say 0.9, it'll just, you know, reduce,
uh, a value from CT one c, CT minus one,
but same set of, uh, si similar kind
of values we also have in other gates as well.
So what I assume is then at every gate we try
to forget some value. Is it not the gate?
Um, so uhhuh slightly, it is different.
You see that here, the weight function is wf
when I'm doing the four gate gate,
Okay? And
here, when we are doing the input gate,
the weight function is WIWC.
So this W-F-W-I-W-C,
they are separate set of weights.
They are not, and that is how they are slightly different.
You are correct in a way that, okay, so
whatever we are trying to do here at the four gate gate,
same thing we are doing at it.
Because here also we have sig mite
and same thing we are trying to do here at ot,
because here also we have SIG mite,
but what makes this little difference is input is same for
ft, IT or ot, but weights are different.
So obviously the overall output
will not be same first of all.
Secondly, I understand that what, uh, if you are trying
to connect how these three sigmoid are, uh, connected,
so here also we try to get some kind of filter vector,
which will act as a filter here also, we get the IT
as a vector, which will act as a filter here also,
we get a vector, which will act as a filter
that is the common LT between these three gate.
If you'll ask me now, what is the difference?
Now this, these filters,
first time this filter will act on CT.
Minus one means my memory, whole memory.
But second time, this filter will act on
the candidate memory.
It is not acting directly on CT minus one.
It is acting on, okay,
what is the new information I've decided to add
to my memory now based on, on that this, it is,
is being multiplied
and third time it is, uh, this particular filter is being,
uh, applied on my after updating input and
Combined, combined CP milestone ct. Okay? Yeah.
That is how they are different. And again, that's
When you say filter that the filter here, obviously try
to, uh, forget something or right, or other I'm,
You can treat, you can, yeah.
If you want to make some kind of correlation
to understand it, yes, that is true because pointer,
but the intuition is different. Different,
Okay. When I
say my forgetting, my
remembering is related to my memory,
Right? Right. Okay, got
it. So it's be thought, if it's related
to memory, then it's forgetting, but otherwise it's, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes. Okay, thanks.
Okay.
I think all of you are able to understand it.
I know it is little complex,
but this is how, uh, with the examples we have
to understand it.
So, uh, RNN lstm we have seen,
and maybe in the next class sir, will explain the GRU
and, uh, I mean, uh, G-R-U-L-S-T-M, both are
are doing the same job.
Okay? One difference, what you will see here,
here we have the four, uh, type of, uh, gates.
I mean, in fact 4, 3, 3 gates, but four neural networks.
But here we have only two gates. Okay?
First one is, uh, I guess, uh, the update, uh,
reset gate or update gate.
These two, we say that, okay, the main difference comes
with the LS TM and GRU is, uh, this CT
and st, we completely make them separate, means I say CT
as my whole memory and ST is my immediate, uh, the short,
short-term memory and CT is my long-term memory.
But in GRU, we don't have these two
memory as separate memory.
We say that no, in GRU we have only one memory that is st.
There is no CT. Here, you see that there is no CT here.
It's only one memory ST.
But then internally we change the architecture.
Instead of having four gate input
or output gate three separate gate,
there is something called reset gate.
And update gate does the same thing, uh, more or less,
but it is less complex as compared to LS tm.
Why? Because I don't have to maintain two separate memory.
Long term. Short term. I am maintaining a single memory,
which is acting same for short term
and long term like we were doing in the case
of RNN, first of all.
But it is different from RNN
because we are doing some update or reset in between.
Okay? And with this reset
and update, we are trying to achieve the same thing.
Forget input and output, what we want to give.
So in a way it is connected,
but we usually say
that GRU is little less complex than LSTM
because here we have less number of parameters also,
but performance by is more
or less they are at the same uh, level, okay?
Performance wise, you may not see much difference
between LS TM and GRU.
Architectural wise, they're different.
But complexity wise, GRU is a little less complex
as compared to LSTM.
So majority of the time you see that, uh,
if you talk about the efficiency complex complexity, GRU,
you should be your preference as compared to lstm.
If you talk about the, uh, performance,
you can choose any of them.
Doesn't matter, okay?
Most of the time they'll perform same in
some cases slightly.
There is a variation also,
there is possibility of all those things.
We'll see about the GRU in detail.
Uh, I'll first go through the demo.
If I get a time, I will start with the GRUA little bit.
But otherwise, in the next class, uh,
we'll we'll go into the detail of the GRU.
Okay? So I'm now moving towards the, uh,
demo, right?
Any questions so far, you can ask me.
Okay? So, uh, what we have
to do is I, uh, planned that, uh, I planned that if,
if we can, uh, build this next word protection task,
the language model task using the LSTM, that is
what is the plan I have.
So here I am, uh, I have already developed this one.
I'll just walk through this, uh, this, this, uh, notebook,
and I'll give you this one for you to you for your practice.
There is no data set, which is, uh, which is,
which is attached here explicitly.
So the data set is written here itself.
One paragraph I'm writing
and the long paragraph that is
what will justify why LS team is required if the paragraph
is not so long that RN can also do that job.
So let us see that. So here, uh, few things.
Initially it'll be common.
What we have already learned in the case of RNN,
a few things will be same, that, uh, pre-processing,
because we are now working with the text that a lot
of pre-processing, which is required all the time, right?
So we will see that one.
So now say that there is one, uh, package, uh,
called NLTK, okay?
That natural language toolkit that we are installing,
and then few more libraries from the torch
or NLTK, we are just importing here.
Now, this is the document one paragraph, okay?
Uh, it is about a particular program,
data science mentorship mentorship program, okay?
And then it has some, it is from this campus X.
Uh, uh, okay.
From there, I have taken this
and, uh, yeah, say that this is my data for that matter.
You can replace it by any paragraph. Doesn't matter. Okay?
So say that this is what I have run.
So this is my document, okay? This is my document.
Now you can see that this document is ready.
What I, what we'll do is usually, uh, in the case of text,
whenever you have to start, you have
to do some pre-processing.
And the first thing, what you have
to do is convert this text in the form of numbers.
And, uh, how do you convert the numbers?
That is what it matters.
That whether you are going to treat, uh, uh,
the whole, whole document as, as a single data
or you want to, you can,
you can create the multiple data points out of this.
All those things are up to you, okay?
I'll show you what I have done today,
but you have to remember
that we are building the next word prediction task, right?
So we need to prepare the input prepared in
the self supervised manner.
You remember we talked in the first semester also,
and in this particular, uh, course also
that self supervised, uh, data we have to create from this.
There is no supervision, which is given,
but we will create the supervision.
Fine. I'll show you all the, all of them.
I'll say that first of all, I start with the tokenization.
For that I'm using the NLTK,
and I'm just downloading some of the, uh, classes.
Now, this is the function which I'm importing
that is called word under tokenized.
This function is already imported, already imported here.
What else could tokenize what it'll do,
it'll take the whole document
and it'll convert as lowercase,
and then it'll do the tokenization of that.
Let me just show you that one by one.
So first of all, if I will just show you this particular
part, okay?
So sorry.
So this one, so you can see that now about the program.
Now you say, see that every word, okay?
Every token, every word, whatever you say,
everything is now in lowercase, there is no capital letter.
You will see, although in this, you will have about
starting a capital P, capital W capital,
but now everything is in the small.
That is the first thing what we are doing. Why?
Because suppose the same word is appear two times, one
as A-B-O-U-T, another one as A-B-U-O-U-T.
I don't want my model to treat these two tokens
as just separate tokens.
I want them to understand as separately, uh, uh,
and same, same token,
but you know, that, uh, the python is case sensitive.
If I'll not do explicitly this part, it'll treat these token
as separately.
And then on top of that, what we are doing is,
I'm just passing it through the, uh, word token,
word under code tokenize.
So let me just run this
and, uh, show that what is coming as it tokens.
You see that what has happened,
so everything it has separated so about is now one token.
There is another token program is another token.
What is another token is another token there,
another token course, another tokens.
Likewise, if you will start, you will see that
that every word, everything, what,
what is there in the document has been tokenized about
the program, what is the, and like that.
And then it has removed some of the tags like slash
and slash and is here, uh, slash
and is here like that, these things.
So that is not coming as a token, okay?
So, uh, uh, all those things it has done,
but you will see that here, uh,
this is not my vocabulary, okay?
This is not why, because you can see that, right?
Same word though is coming here also here.
So, but in the vocabulary,
you have the unique setup token, right?
That is what the, that is still we have to build.
So this is what we do,
and now we are building our vocabulary.
Once we run this one tokens already, we just have to
find the unique tokens from this tokens,
and then we'll build our vocabulary.
So what we are doing is initially in my vocabulary,
I am keeping just one token that is unknown
to handle at the test time.
If there is a new token come not there in my vocabulary,
I'll assign zero to that, okay?
Now, what I'm doing is I'm running a four loop.
So for, for, uh, token in, uh,
for token in what is, what will,
what this will do, let me just show you.
Let, let me show you this.
Um, sorry, let me show you this one here.
So what, what this is doing is this particular
line counter token.
So it is simply counting each token,
each token in the whole document,
like say about came two times though is coming.
69 times program is coming,
just kind counting the frequency.
So by doing this one, what it returning is, if you see
that it is returning key, which is that token
and its frequency as a value.
So anyway, it has, it has, it has given me the unique set
of token, which is available in my document
by counting this one, how many times that token is coming.
I have, I have got now the unit set up tokens.
So what I'll do from this, uh, from this
dictionary key value pair, I will only use the keys.
I will only use the key. I'll ignore the value.
Value is not, uh, important for me.
These keys were important
because from these keys, I was building my vocabulary,
unique setup tokens.
I was building my vocabulary. So I'll simply put keys, okay?
Like, like you can see here.
Uh, so it is, I'll simply put keys here,
and now you can see that it'll only give me the keys,
the values there discarded.
That's all. And this is what I wanted also,
that's why this particular line.
Now, once we have all those unique setup tokens,
which is there one by one, I'll select those token
and I'll start assigning the index number.
How, by just seeing the current, current length
of my dictionary, which is one.
So the first token, if it is about, uh,
the word is about token is about the index will be one,
then I'll have two tokens in my dictionary.
So third token, suppose it is the,
it is the index number two.
Now I have three tokens in my dictionary.
Suppose the fourth token is program.
So index number is three. So likewise.
So I'm just increasing the, uh, uh, the finding.
What is the size of my vocabulary
and length of my vocabulary
and assigning that it value itself for the next token index.
And that is how I'm getting now, token
and it's index number.
Okay? This is my vocabulary.
This is how I am building my vocabulary. Fine. Okay?
So I will just, uh,
remove this, fine.
So my vocabulary I have built, so I can also find
what is the length of my vocabulary.
You can see that it is 2 89, 2 89. You need tokens. I have.
Now, this is not enough still to process it
with the RNN or lstm, right?
My tokens are vocabulary are built in indexes I have
created, but I need to come up with the same, uh, uh,
sentences, what I have in my whole document.
So it is a, a sequence of words.
I need to also form the sequence of indices, right?
My data set is still not in the format
of the sequence of words.
So that's why we are, what we are doing is first of all,
the whole document I'm splitting
based on the new line, okay?
You can split based on the multiple things. Here.
It is being splitted based on the new line.
So you see that in your document.
You will see multiple slash and operator, right?
Slash and character, so slash and slash and slash.
And so wherever you are seeing slash
and so that is, that is what, that's where it is.
Breaking it, splitting it,
and then next up to wherever you will get the next slash
and that will treat it, uh, as a one sentence.
That is what is being done here.
So document, uh,
document is being splitted based on the slash okay?
Input sequence. Input sequence. Alright?
So you can see that now I have these set of these, these,
uh, uh, these set of, uh, data.
So I have divided my whole document into set of sentences.
This is my first sentence. This is my second sentence.
This is my third sentence and so on. Okay?
So, uh, yes, this is,
this is the, this is one thing.
Now, if you want to see that,
how many total sentence I have, okay?
This is a list. Um,
so you have total 78 sentences.
Likewise. So I have total, uh, dataset. I just 78, 78.
But each sentence is of having different length.
So here I have four tokens.
Here I have say that eight tokens somewhere.
I have 10 tokens, 20 tokens, and likewise.
So we'll see that how to, uh, how
to, how we are processing that.
We'll see that. But this is how we are,
why our data is as of now.
Next, what I'm doing is
because first of all, I have to convert the, uh, these,
these sentences as, uh, uh, sequence of indices.
Then only I will start processing it with the network.
So this is the function text to indices.
It'll take the text, each sentence,
convert it into the sequence of indices.
So sentence and vocab I have to give.
So for each sentence vocabulary I have written
where each token index number is already given.
And I'll create the, uh,
new list called numerical sentences,
which will have the sentences, but in the form of indices.
So these function, these follow loop will work for that
for token in sentence, for token in sentence, uh,
and then, uh, whatever sentence you're receiving here, uh,
it will check that if that token is in the vocabulary.
And then we'll simply write
that from the vocabulary, whatever.
It's, uh, index number that will come from here.
Suppose you will print vocab token.
It'll give you its index number.
So that index will be appended in this particular list,
and sentence by sentence will do that one.
Otherwise, we are going
to upend the index of the unknown token.
Suppose any new word will appear, okay?
If it is not there in my vocabulary.
This we have seen in the last class also.
Uh, so in the same way we are just building that.
And here, here,
this is just a function which we have defined text
to sequence text, two indices.
I'm calling the function here, okay?
I'm calling the function here.
So first this function, uh, internally,
we'll call the word underscore token, I, which is internal,
doing the, uh, uh, lower casing.
And we are also passing the vocabulary.
So after this,
after this, you can, you can actually see
what is coming in this, uh, input
numerical sentences.
You can see this. So what has come in, now, it has given me
the sentences, but now sentences are in the form of index.
So 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3.
Why I'm saying is because the first sentence, which is like,
which is like about the program.
About the program, that means that about index is one.
The index is two, program index is three.
That's why it is 1, 2, 3. Okay?
And you can check that, uh, you can check that also, that
what is the index for this?
And if suppose you want to check that, I will use this.
Mm, just to show you that. Okay?
Suppose my token is about, okay, sorry, I have
to give it as key, right?
Uh, about, so it is one if I'll say about the
it is two and about the program, it is three.
That's why first sentence was 1, 2, 3,
because it is about the program.
Likewise, you can also check what the, you can match it
and it'll come correctly, right?
It is just a representation
of sentence in the form of indices.
Now that is ready. Okay? I delete this.
Now, uh, this is one of the sentence, that's all.
And now I have to create the self supervised data.
That is what is the next thing.
So how do you create that self supervised data?
So we know that, right?
So what we do in the case of self supervised,
suppose we have this whole as a one sequence.
So we start with four.
We say that four is an input, five is an output.
Then I'll say four, five is an input, two is an output.
Then I'll say 4, 5, 2 is an input, six is an output.
Then 4, 5, 2, 6 is an input. Seven is an output.
Self supervised. Every next index is going to be the output
for all the indices,
which has come in the past for that sequence.
Okay? For example, if you talk about 1, 2, 3
for the first sentence, 1, 2, 3.
So one is an input. Who is an output?
If one, two is an input, three is an output, and that's all.
We can form only these two self supervised
data from the first sentence.
But from this particular sequence, I can form many,
like I started with four.
Then five is an output. 4, 5, 2 is an output.
4, 5, 2, 6 is output. 4, 5, 6, 7 is an output.
4, 5, 6, 7, 8 is output and so on.
You can see that it can still go more. Okay?
So that is how it is created.
How we have created that using this piece of code.
So what I've done, I have taken the sentence from my
each input numerical sequence.
It is a list of list.
Remember one by one, one of the list will be taken,
and now it is in a group.
It is going from I to the range of whatever is the length
of this list or next list, whatever.
It'll come. So it is length is like say that, uh,
next suppose for zero, how it'll run.
I'll still tell you. So it'll go from one to three.
And every time in this training sequence,
I'm appending something.
What? I'm appending, I'm appending, I'm starting
with one means I I zero
and going up to I plus one, going up to I plus one.
So first time the zero value is one
and I plus one value is two.
So it's about giving one, two.
Next time I value is uh, um, it is starting
with this and going up to I plus one, which is this one.
So starting point is zero and going up to I plus one.
That's how we are creating sentence. Okay?
I think you can, uh, you're able to understand that one.
That's all. Now, uh,
after that, what I'm doing is I'm simply calculating
what is the, uh,
because what I said you earlier, you have
to process when your dataset is too huge, you need
to process the input as a batch.
You can also process one by one all the sentences,
which I did earlier also in the previous class, uh, rn
and I actually put batch size call to one.
But usually you don't do that because your data is so huge.
If you will pass it one by one, then it'll take
huge amount of time, right?
So for every input you have to do the back propagation.
And suppose you have one, 1 million input, 1 million update.
It'll take huge time for the model two green.
So what we do, we create some batches.
Now, the problem with the batches, problem
with the batches like that, say that in a batch,
I have a data like this,
and just showing you a few data, fund data is of length.
Two, one data of sequence length.
Three, one data is of sequence length.
Two, one data is of sequence length, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So every sequence length is different.
Every sequence length is different.
Suppose I decide to keep the batch size 32.
So same problem, okay, same problem.
Your neural network cannot process this
different sequence length.
Okay? Obviously I understand elast, uh, Altium can, uh,
handle the variable length sequence.
That is what we talked earlier.
But when you are processing
and in the form of batch for batch, you have to fix
what is the sequence length you are to process.
Like for a single, if you are processing single,
single, then it is fine.
You can process it whatever is the variable and sequence.
But if you plan to process it as a batch,
which will do okay, we have to make sure that
what is the maximum length of sequence, which will go
as an input, means you are deciding
what is the maximum time stamp
for each sequence you are going to process.
Okay? So ob I understand that that will be again, uh,
some problem, uh, because we need
to do some padding at zeros.
But yeah, that is how you can process the batch, okay?
That is how you can process the batch.
So what I'm doing is, first of all, giving all the 9 42,
these sequences like that, you'll have 9 42 sequences.
I'm just finding what are the maximum length sequence
turns out to be 62.
So I have decided that every sequence length,
I'll make it as 62.
I'll make it 62 for each of these sequence length,
So how I'll do, I'll add 60 zeros before these one
and two not after,
because I don't want my output to be zero anytime,
because initially if it is zero, that is okay,
but later I don't want that.
Okay? Next word to be zero. Okay?
That's why I will add, I'll do the padding,
but padding will come before this one too.
So 60 here, here, it'll come 59 here, come 60 here,
it'll come 59 here, it'll come 58 0.
Here it come 57 and so on.
So that is what is being done here. 62.
First of all, I have decided,
sorry, training
So this one, okay, okay, this I have to drop.
Alright, so now say that the first sequence is one, two,
I'm doing some kind of padding, okay?
Padding how I'm doing, I have to add zeros. How many zeros?
The maximum length for the list in the entire corpus is 62.
So it'll return 62 and length of the sequence.
This current sequence is two. So this will return two.
So 62 minus two will be 60.
60 into zero will be 60 zeros. Okay? 60 zeros.
And that will add to my sequence, that will,
that I'll add to my sequence.
So this current sequence is this one,
and I'll add that to my sequence.
So I will just show you that what it'll do basically,
and it'll do for all the sequences.
So if I'll show you zero first data, uh,
okay, just a length.
So, uh, pad it sequence.
Uh, you see this,
what has happened is earlier it was like one, two.
Now it is like all the way 0, 0, 0, 0, 60 zeros. It had it.
And now at last one, two, this is what I was saying.
And same thing is can be shown in the form of like this.
In the next case, when it is 1, 2, 3,
like 1, 2, 3 will be at last
and all zeros, 59 zeros will be added.
Okay? That is what we are doing in the case of padding,
because I need to process them as a batch.
If I don't process them as batch.
This padding is not required. Okay?
Not required, which
that's why we did not do this step in the previous, uh,
demo when we were seeing the RNN fine.
That's all, that's all my all pre-processing is done.
The only thing which is left it, I have
to separate the input and label input and output.
Okay? So what I'm doing these two lines, X is an input
and y is an output.
So in the x I'm selecting all the row one by one.
In these row we have many columns, 62 columns in each row.
So what I've decided, I will select all the column except
the last one because last one is my output.
Okay? So here you can see it is going only up to one.
Here it is going only up to two.
Here it is going only up to four. Last column.
I'm not selecting to 2, 3, 5.
These here, 2 86, not selecting two.
So it is going only up to 1 76, 2 86, and 2 87.
You can see that, right? So not selecting the last column,
where is the last column is it is going in y selecting all
the rows and the column only the last column minus one.
Okay? And that is coming in Y. So XY is also now ready.
Okay? You can see that right? X, Y is also ready.
I will just run these. X is ready,
Y is ready, and that's all.
Now it, uh, now we have to just build our model.
So before building our model, we have
to build these two classes, custom dataset classes
and data loader class.
So the custom dataset class, we have three, three, uh,
usual, uh, methods, the construc method,
then length, and then get item.
What we are doing is we are simply passing X
and Y, which we have just created, okay?
In self y length will give me what is the total length
and, uh, gate item one by one,
whatever item data load will ask, it'll fetch
because now I'm going to press the, create the batches
of 32, and with 32 data will come that I don't know.
So that will come completely randomly.
So that, I don't know, that's why this, uh,
get item will give me those indexes
for which I'm going to create the batches.
Okay? So this custom dataset class
we have seen multiple times.
Then after custom dataset class,
I'm creating an object for of it.
Okay? This I have seen earlier.
So data loader class, data loader class will take the
dataset, this dataset create the badge.
We'll decide what is the badge side and shuffling will keep.
That's all. Okay?
These are all the things we have seen multiple times.
Hopefully there is no issue in understanding any of this.
Now it comes to the LSTM model.
We have to build the model, okay?
Now, this LS model building is exactly same
what we have done in the case of RN.
Okay? If you have understood the last class demo, well,
now this piece of code is exactly same, almost same.
There is no, uh, no, uh, changes. Okay?
So if you remember, we had a constructor inside that first,
we decided the embedding layer, okay?
Because my, uh, input, input means I've decided
that I'll process each sequence of plan 62, right?
Decided now 62 inputs we are feeding.
So you will have 62 timestamp in the LSTM timestamp.
So first timestamp, second timestamp, all the way up
to 62 timestamp.
Now, all of them will be represented in the vocabulary
size, a one hot vector.
Their representation will be as a one hot vector.
And that one hot vector dimension will be vocabulary size
and vocabulary size,
I guess we have seen earlier somewhere vocab,
vocab, Uh, 2 89.
So ev so 62 timestamp
and every input is represented at 2 89 dimensional vector.
That is a vocabulary size. Okay?
Obviously all zeros, if it is zeros input is zero.
If it is some index, then
that particular index will be high rest all zeros.
So what we are doing is the 2 89, I'm, I'm just
down sampling it to, uh, down, uh, sampling it to 100.
So my embedding layer will have a hundred neurons,
and for each 2 89 dimensional vector,
it will gimme the a hundred dimensional vector as an output.
That is the work of the embedding layer. Okay?
Now, this a hundred dimensional output will go
as an input to the LST.
Now, this is the input at each time stamp will feed
one, one, uh, uh, token as an input.
The token input dimension is a hundred.
And how many timestamp?
Uh, so, uh, how many, how many timestamp?
So time stamp will be 60,
Okay?
Uh, right timestamp, we are not changing.
Timestamp will be 62. Okay? And what is this? One 50?
One 50 is the neurons. O okay?
One 50 is the neurons. Okay?
Now, there might be slight, uh, uh, confusion.
I, I understand that. Why if it is one 50.
So I'm, I'm keeping my, uh,
input dimension here as a hundred.
And my, uh, output dimension from the LSTM is, I just want
to show you that figure so that it'll be more clear to you.
Let me just show you this one.
So, uh, let me go here.
Okay, So XT
XT is passed to the embedding layer.
Remember, XT is not going. XT was one hot vector
going through the embedding layer.
Embedding layer output is going here.
So embedding layer output is a hundred dimension input.
And what I'm saying is, uh, one 50
is the number of neurons here.
So sigma, what you're seeing, Sigma or 10 X
or sigma, all of them will have 1 50, 1 50, 1 50, 1 50.
So one 50 means it'll give a vector output, one 50
because sigma will give the one 50 output,
which will come one 50.
Output will come here, one 50 output will come here, here,
and here, okay?
According to my, uh, code one 50.
So you might be confused, sir, then one 50 here,
a hundred here, and not match, not matching, right?
So basically what will happen,
because this, uh, I have told that right?
This vector, uh, uh,
so this particular vector, what you're getting here,
and this CT has to match, okay?
It, it has to match.
Otherwise there is, you can't be doing this.
Pointwise multiplication. POINTWISE multiplication, okay?
So, uh, this vector, this vector
and this vector, that means the vector,
which you can getting from this sigma, the vector ct
and the vector hd, these three should match, okay?
Now xd, you may keep it as same,
and XD might be different.
You can see that, right? Because xd,
what we have done here is XD was initially woke cap size,
then we reduced 200, okay?
Then we reduce 200.
But a, uh, so vector point wise, multiplication, we are,
we don't bother till here.
But once it is one 50, say that my XT is now represented
by this neural network layer where we have the sigmoid.
Now one 50 dimensional vector we are getting,
then it should match with the dimension of ct, match
with the dimension of xd.
So these three should definitely match.
Otherwise you can't be doing this, uh,
element wise multiplication.
So XT is XT dimension can vary. That is how it is.
So if you have understood it,
the XD also should be same XD also vector,
but this vector dimension is depending on
your VAB size and all.
So it'll not be exactly same as this CTST
or ft, whatever you are getting here, okay?
So, uh, let us be very clear on that particular point. Okay?
So here we have one 50 dimensional output from that, uh,
from that mite, from that sig sig mite.
So means one vector where we have one 50 values, that's all.
And here also you will have the same here also,
you'll have the same here also.
So how many timestamp like XT will go XT plus one,
then it'll go all the way up to XT X 62.
So if it is one, then it'll go 62 timestamp.
Because timestamp, we have already fixed 62 6 length,
we have already fixed 62.
That is not going to vary, okay?
So after doing all those 62 timestamp,
so this particular line will run
for 62 times stamp this particular line, okay?
Once it'll run for the 62
stamp, uh, fine.
Uh, basically what is happening is 62 times stamp. Why?
It'll run, because every sequence length I have fixed as 62.
If I would have processed every length,
every sequence separately, passage equal to one,
then it would've run only for one time stamp
and it would've given one output.
This, for this particular sequence,
it would've run two times stamp,
but would've run third time.
Uh, third uh, output, two timestamp, put, have run this
one, this, it'll run for two timestamp.
Likewise, you can turn, but
because we have padded now, it'll every
sequence length I have fixed at 62.
That is what I have done, okay?
So this particular line will definitely run
for 62 times, okay?
Whatever sequence, whatever input you are feeding.
After running this for 62 timestamp,
then we have a linear layer, we have a linear layer,
we in the linear layer, what we are doing is
what this one 50, uh,
or dimensional output, uh,
whatever you are getting from the LSTM will feed one 50.
So here, you can now imagine, so this, this is my output
after the 62 timestamp.
So HD will have the same dimension.
What you're getting from this, all these gates, 1 50, 1 50,
so that one 50 only the output for this HD also.
So that dimension, you can pass it through some, some, uh,
fully connected layer, because ultimately you have
to boil it down to the next word.
What is the next word, which I can predict.
So that one 50 will be then further mapped
to your vocab size, okay?
And then you will put the soft max on top of that,
and then you will get a probability for a particular word,
which is probably the next word to be predicted, okay?
That is how these three lines are going to execute.
Okay? So, uh, let me know if you have any confusion in this,
any, any confusion in this.
Okay? So now, uh, what is happening is that, uh, uh, this
here we have decided that this is going to be my constructor
and, uh, we have to write the forward.
So this is just a blueprint of how my network I'm going
to design and forward pass will actually pass the input
of one layer as an, uh, output of one layer
as an input to the next layer.
So you can see that plus we are calling this
embedding, passing.
The XX is my input, the vector input.
I will go to the embedding layer, give the
how many dimensional hundred
dimensional vector as an output.
Now that in that embedded will go as an input
to the LSTM, okay?
To the LSTM. You can see that LS TM we passing embedded.
Now this embedded layer here,
there is a slightly change from the RNN in the case of RNN.
You remember I said that for every time a stamp you get
to out means for, for the, for the RNN, I said that
because RN looks like that, right?
And suppose you have three times stamp here.
So for every time a stamp, you get an output, ST minus one,
st, st plus one.
So RNN once you will run for all the timestamp,
it'll give you for every timestamp, separate output
and final timestamp, whatever is the output.
There are two different tensors as you give you
as an output, two different tensors.
Similarly, in the case of LSTM,
you get two different tensors for every timestamp,
whatever is the output that also you get
and whatever is the final time stamp
output that also you will get.
Okay? But there is one more, uh, nesting here.
It every time stamp. Also, there are two output.
One is ct, one is st.
Like in the case of rn,
and every time ST stem, there is a single output st.
But in the LSTM, every time stem, along with the st,
you have ct also because there are memory cell
also you're maintaining, right?
So now the same thing, you will be able to see,
so intermediate hidden estate output you will get
and the final or final hidden estate output.
But in the final hidden estate output,
you will get the final cell estate output also.
So what is the final memory state?
So that there are three different set
of vectors you are getting as an or.
You, you see that, but this is little different from the RN,
otherwise everything is same.
Okay? I am interested in final hidden estate output.
So I, I'm a state, I'm interested in this st plus one,
the final hidden estate output,
because on top of that, I'll put the linear layer
and get the next word protection.
So that is what is taken from here.
Final hidden estate output.
Squeezing just because of the dimensionality, mismatched
because so far it was like batch.
Then, uh, uh, best size that what is the sequence length?
Then what is the dimension?
But after this, we are having the linear layer,
which doesn't require the sequence number
of sequence length and all.
So we have just squeezed it. You can check that how it is.
You can print each of these layer one by one and check
and finally passing it through the fully connected layer,
this linear layer,
and it is giving me the output factor, this output vector.
Then what we are doing is, uh, okay,
so once we have this forward pass ready,
I'm calling this lstm LSTM model, which we have created,
creating an object of it, passing it, my, uh, input, okay?
Input, uh, uh, length.
Initially it'll be a, uh, vocab, uh, whatever is the, uh,
vocab length fine.
So let me run this first.
Okay? So you see that, right?
For embedding layer, vocab size was your, your input.
Same thing. I'm doing the initial input,
uh, whatever is the dimension.
I'm passing it here.
Then transferring my, uh, model to the GPU.
Then some of the parameters like learning rate,
loss function, which will have softmax also remember the
loss function itself will have the softmax implemented.
So there is no softmax here,
otherwise, softmax is here itself.
Then we have optimizer as.
So this we have implemented,
and finally we have the training loop.
In the training loop, we decide, okay,
how many times it is going to run.
And then we are creating the data loader, batch batch sizes,
batch X, batch y.
Transferring it to the device means GPU,
making the optimizer gradient has zero.
Getting the output from the model by passing the x,
giving the output vector, pass it through the loss
backward means calculating the gradient,
optimizing all my parameter and calculating the loss.
These are all we have seen multiple times.
So I'm not spending much time on this.
So now the law, this, this will start training.
So you can see that the loss is decreasing.
Now, after to this, what will happen, uh, let it run once.
Suppose bottle is trained, it's an expert prediction task.
So now my model should do the word prediction task.
So for that one, this is the function define prediction.
What I have to pass the trained model, the vocabulary,
which I have already have from the training data,
sample training, and the new text for which I want
to do the next word prediction.
Okay? So when this text will come, this may have one word,
this may have two words.
This may have three words. Everything is possible, okay?
Because every text, first of all, you have to tokenize,
convert it into the index based on the vocabulary,
and then do the padding.
Every text has to be padded into the length of 62
because that is what we do.
We did at the training time also.
So we can't vary at the test time, right?
So at the test time, also, this padding is required.
So 62 dimensional text, uh, list
of indices will create anyhow, okay?
So these three lines are seen.
Then whatever will get ready, text, we'll pass it
through the model, we'll ask, do the prediction, okay?
And it'll give me a vector, vector of probability,
distribution, probability of of, of size, vocab size, okay?
Whatever is my VAB site, because any
word can be the next word.
And then, because softex will give one
of the word the highest probability
that I will take it from here
and I'll find what is that index
for which it is giving me the highest probability.
I'll map it through my vocab and get that word.
Okay, get that word. You see that this is
how the training is done, and let me run this
particular function.
So this function is done.
Now I'll do is I'll call this function prediction.
I'll call this function prediction, passing model,
and vocab as it is, whatever we have done.
And uh, so say
that I will start with very simple.
I'll start with can, okay?
A simple, this text is now can, okay,
and I'll ask, what is the next word?
So it is asking can we, now, if I'm passing, can we,
it is saying can we pay?
Okay, am I'm saying can we pay?
It's saying, can we pay the, okay, can we pay the now,
can we pay the entire, okay, uh,
entire amount.
Likewise, you see that whatever previous set
of tokens I'm giving it is now able to gimme the next word.
What is going to be based on my corpus and training, right?
So this is happening one by one.
I can also decide, okay, how many tokens output I want.
Like you can see in the case of the LLMs
and all, they already have decided, okay,
how many maximum token can give you
as an output if you want to.
So you can also say that next 10 tokens I want,
and you can use this time, uh, for
library package.
Uh, and you can simply put time sleep is called
to 0.5 every time it'll generate something.
So say that, I will say can, again, I'll say start with can
I also can also give the capital letter.
Doesn't matter because anyway,
the first pre-processing it is doing okay,
it is doing the pre-processing.
So see, can see can we pay the entire amount
of rupees, five, six, double zero, all that.
So 10 tokens, that's all. And that's where it has a stop.
If I want it to give 20 tokens, it can give that also,
can we pay the entire amount of,
okay, you can see that, right?
Even the question marks and uh, up to 20 tokens,
because I have decided it can go.
So this is how the language model works,
and STM is doing a good job, at least for the corpus,
what it has seen, it has, it is now able
to remember the long term and short term context quite well.
But the problem, problem, uh, comes,
okay, actually there is a problem.
Problem is the corpus. Okay?
Uh, suppose I will ask how, okay, I,
and I'll ask, okay, gimme 20 tokens,
how will I be informed about the,
so basically somehow it is going into my corpus every time
and seeing that, okay, where, uh, see that how I give
it picked this particular,
how will I informed about the upcoming classes
and somehow it has given me the output like
that upcoming classes
and then to then suppose if I pay.
So that is how it is.
So why it is giving, suppose if I pay, uh,
how will I inform where it was?
So this, this sentence has given and some somewhere else.
Also, it is started giving.
So what I'm trying to say is, I'm trying to say is
this particular model is good
for the data, what it has seen.
Suppose something else, it'll come,
then it'll start failing.
Okay? So for example, how are
you, how are you?
Okay now see
how are you will get a mail from now see?
So you understood, right? What is the problem? How are you?
Is my seed text for which I want the model
to give me the 20 next token.
What it is seeing it is seeing my training corpus
and uh, somehow somewhere it is starting from then onwards
maybe correct, but for this, how are you,
the output is not correct
and the problem is not
with the model problem has understood the data quite well.
The problem is what the data itself dataset was very small,
and you see that there is just one paragraph
having just a few 9 42 I guess sequences.
That is what we processed.
So you should have very used amount of data in order
to get very generic kind of responses.
And that is what you see in the case
of when LS TM will work better in those cases,
but you should train it with a huge amount of data.
That is what is lagging here.
So that's why it was given that.
And finally this particular line is simply
showing, okay, sorry.
So simply showing the what is the overall accuracy
of this particular system so that you can see by yourself,
but it is simply the creating another, uh, dataset, uh,
and then just finding the equity
because my labels are available.
Yeah. So that is all, that is all from the today's, uh,
demo from the LSTM for next word particular.
This is a language model using LSTM.
Okay, you can ask me some questions if you have
Sir, in case of time series data, numeric data.
Mm-hmm. So how we'll, uh, decide the window size, sir?
So, uh, time series data, uh, if I rightly understood, row
by row, you have multiple features, right? Go by.
Yes, sir. Yes. So what, see, anyway, uh,
what I understand is each feature, each row, each having the
sequence, same, I mean, so length
of the each row is same, correct?
That is first thing, length will not vary for you.
So padding and all will not be required,
but you can always decide if how many batch,
batch sides you can always decide.
Okay? So window, you are talking in terms of this, uh,
uh, sequence length, right?
Yes, sir. Yes sir. Padding, which we did 60.
Uh, so padding is not required here.
62 we did,
because each row you see
that each row was of different
length. This is not first row.
Yes sir. This second Row and each were varying
because I wanted to process it as a badge.
I did the padding and decided 62 as a sequence length.
But in the case of time series data, what you will have is
row length will be common.
Yes. For, for most of the, for for all the rows, right?
And hence you don't need the padding.
You can simply create the batch and process it simple.
So the window will be directly depending on
how many columns you have in your data. That's all.
Yes. Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. Others?
Is there a relation between choosing batch size
versus sequence length?
Should be less or more for a patient?
No, there is no such a relation. I see.
Sequence length, west side.
No, no, there is no such relation.
Uh, because sequence length can be anything bad, bad.
There is a relation between batch size
and the corpus length.
You can see that it means how many supposed have a 1 0 2 4,
uh, row in my data,
I can prefer batch size of 32 1 28.
It all depends, right?
What is my computational power or, uh, I have in my system?
So there is a diff there is a relation between batch size
and the corpus size,
but there is no relation between batch size
and the sequence length, individual sequence length.
Yeah.
Okay, thank.
Okay. So I think, uh, you're able
to understand the internal working of the L-S-T-M-R-N-N, uh,
which is very important to know.
GRU you will understand suppose you understood the LSTM,
understand the GRU is very simple, little bit, uh, little,
uh, different architecture.
It has philosophies in in the GRU,
which will explain the next class.
Okay? And then few more things are left in the course,
like we'll go to the sequence to sequence model
and we want to explain the attention on top
of the sequence to sequence model.
That's all transformer.
Initially we thought that we'll touch
and suppose we are not able to cover much.
That is also okay because the next course, next semester
we'll start with the LLM.
There again, we will start
with the transformer architecture itself.
Okay? So these are all the,
and we have roughly three to four weeks left, uh, till 21st
of this, uh, next month.
So eight to 10 class will have more, no,
Yes, the eight class, no Eight class.
Sir, I have a question, sir.
In what situations does this LS TM fail to capture this, uh,
long-term dependencies, sir, even though it's uh, designed,
uh, I mean it is designed in such a way there,
if there any situations like that,
See, ideally, uh, l TM should not fail in that,
that's why the architecture is defined.
I've defined like that, but you never know that.
Okay, if the sequence is still very long, uh, say
that we have thousand page, uh,
sequence thousand page books, right?
I think you never know. It may fail also,
but then that also will not happen.
If you'll have the enough amount of data
and you train the LSTM with the huge amount
of data, that should not happen.
That is what ideally it sees.
Okay? So there's no upper limit for this. Uh,
There is no upper limit for this.
Yes. Like in the case of LLM, uh,
we don't have any upper limit.
You can't say that it'll fail.
Only situation when it'll fail is if you are not training
it, it with the sufficient amount of data.
If you're training it, then ideally it should not fail.
Yeah, there might be some other problem, which we have
to see, but ideally it should not fail. Yeah,
Understood sir.
Yeah, sir. And also one more thing.
The mid semester marks were updated in the LMS
and the Excel sheet,
but whatever questions we have discussed,
those were not updated.
Uh, the 0.002 and zero point,
Uh, two question, we thought now that we,
Yeah. One question is updated,
sir,
but this 0.002 question is not updated.
Uh, sir, actually we'll do it, sir. We'll do it.
And up later upload very soon.
Okay. Okay. We'll do that. Thank you, sir.
Uh, one small question, sir.
Uh, how can we implement, uh, this in, I mean, uh, we come
with respect to the stock market
and uh, this prediction, this kind of thing.
So I'm having a little bit, uh, ambiguity here, sir,
because here it, uh, the data will be sequential
as well as the time series.
Both, uh, both will be there. Uh, how to
You can do that, actually you can do that.
Okay. So, uh, see, I I I,
the same question was asked actually by RA also
that your now data is like, uh, uh,
sequence, sequence, sequence.
You're saying that, uh, in a time stamp manner, it is coming
that this is day one data, day one row, then day two row
and the day one also you have multiple,
multiple input, which is available.
So I, I said that you can,
what you can do is in a single row, whatever is the number.
We lost your voice, sir.
Alright, sorry. So what I was telling is that, uh, yeah,
you have a row, each row is representing say that day one,
day two, day three, day four.
Now each row anyway, it has some, some number
of columns, right?
So what you can do is if those columns,
you can also process all those, uh, row wise,
row wise as a sequence.
You can treat it also that this is the first row
and timestamp is that row itself.
That is also possibility
because day one is the first timestamp
and all the associated column is the features.
Like here one hot is a features 1, 0 0 0 0.
There, the each column is the features,
and each row is going to be your, uh, each row is going
to be your timestamp.
That day one, this is the input I'm passing.
Then day two, this is the input. I'm passing day three.
So, but there you have to make a window that you want
to do some kind of forecasting
and you want to see, okay, last 10 days, what was the trend?
Based on that, what will be the trend?
On the 11th day, you can make a window of, uh, 10.
So in that case, how many times stamp you'll have,
you'll have 10 times stamp.
You can have 10 times stamp
and each time stamp, what is the input size?
It depends on how many columns you have.
So that is how you can implement.
So window, you can, uh, vary, uh, obviously that, okay,
how many, uh, days you want to see in the past.
Sometimes you want to see one month past data
and then you want to do the prediction.
The window will be 13th.
So 30 timestamp, it will come in that particular case.
Yeah. Okay, sir. Thank you sir. Okay. Yeah.
Alright. So I guess, uh, this is fine for today.
We'll meet on Monday. We'll continue the GRD.
Okay? Yes, thank you. Yeah, sure. So thank you and update
This notebook.
Uh, I'll, I'll share it with you.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you, sir. Thank sir, sir.
Thank you, sir. It was very good explanation, sir.
Thank you. Thank, yes sir. Thank you sir. Thank sir.
Thank you sir.